[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Gabriel messire je
suis assistant de direction et de
gestion au bureau des transports
je suis entré au Sénat en janvier 2002
en tant que agent des services et je
suis désormais assistant de direction de
gestion par la voie de promotion d'un
concours interne que j'ai passé en 2012
donc nous avons commission de faciliter
le quotidien des sénateurs puisque nous
occupons de toute la partie logistique
de leur de leur déplacement pour qu'ils
puissent se consacrer le planement à
leur mission parlementaire nous
utilisons tous les logiciels mes
dispositions des agences de voyages pour
remplir nos tâches quotidiennes
doubler des logiciels dédiés Sénat pour
tout ce qui est de la partie réservation
de véhicules
automobiles et toute la partie comptable
également au sein du bureau nous sommes
polyvalent pour pouvoir tenir les
permanences et prendre des révélations
aussi bien en train qu'en avion que pour
les véhicules c'est un poste où il faut
un certain sang-froid puisqu'il faut
savoir gérer les aléas du quotidien des
parlementaires puisque c'est à nous de
nous adapter à eux et pas le contraire
dans l'exercice de mes fonctions il faut
avoir une grande rigueur pour gérer les
aléas quotidiens et garder le fil de ce
que l'on fait puisqu'on est très souvent
interrompu soit par le téléphone soit
par des réservations de ceintures qui se
présente dans le bureau le poste que
j'occupe actuellement est un poste
exigeant puisque le fonctionnons au
rythme de la séance et nous sommes donc
amenés à faire des permanences du lundi
au samedi le midi comme le soir ce qu'il
y a de bien dans le poste d'assistant de
direction et de gestion c'est que on
peut être amené tout au long d'une
carrière à occuper différents emplois
différentes fonctions puisqu'il a autant
de postes et d'emplois différents que de
direction personnellement je ne me lasse
pas de mon environnement de travail qui
est tout de même un palais du 17e siècle
et j'apprécie tout particulièrement
également le fait de travailler dans une
institution en dimension humaine nous
sommes quotidiennement en contact avec
les sénateurs ou les commissions pour
les déplacements des missions
parlementaires et pour se faire nous
avons également des relations avec les
agences de voyages ou les compagnies
aériennes pour mettre leurs offres en
concurrence
[Musique]